a little bit more information on that
breaking news this hour about multiple
people being injured after a large ship
was dislodged in high winds in an
Edinburgh Dry Dock let's get the latest
from our Scotland correspondent Connor
Gillis Connor what do you know
this has been a morning of very high
winds here in Scotland and very dramatic
pictures emerging earlier on this
morning uh this vessel leading at a what
appears to be a 45 degree angle
in the docked in Dry Dock at least which
is in Edinburgh now we know that
emergency services were called just
after half past eight this morning
police ambulance fire Services uh all
called to reports that the ship had
become dislodged from its Holdings at
Imperial dock uh in lease around 8 35 we
know that this is a vessel it's 76
meters long it is a research vessel
called the petrol and it is owned we
understand by the estate of the
Microsoft co-founder Paul Allen now it's
believed that this vessel had been used
for deep water searches for shipwrecks
and for war Graves at Sea and it had
been in Dry Dock undergoing assessment
undergoing tests by the teams in
Edinburgh when this incident happened
now the pictures have been fairly
dramatic over the course course of the
last number of hours showing that vessel
appearing to be on its side and Sky News
understands that multiple people have
been injured in this incident it's
unclear the extent of those injuries or
if any of them have been taken in a blue
light ambulance to hospital those
details are still to emerge but we do
know that there are a number of
casualties in this incident uh the
Scottish Ambulance Service telling Sky
News that it sent five ambulances an air
ambulance three trauma teams and other
resources to the scene we also know that
the fire service attended and police
Scotland is also in attendance as well a
huge emergency response as you would
expect in this circumstance while the
details are still emerging this is still
an ongoing operation and one of the
local councilors in the area has said
that this has been to quote terrifying
for those on board and this is an
ongoing situation that they will be
keeping an eye on